welcome to the iron Lord podcast episode
number 10 and we are live in the
building it's good to be back we have
The Usual Suspects at the round table a
little smaller group today but we just
uh definitely happy to be back had some
workout some Kinks but we glad you got
stuck with us but of course the Lords
are here and I got my man the EXs gamer
the Lord that takes nothing less than
the premium experience oh
my man Lord King what's going on Lord
King oh well you know I'm live right now
feeling real good right just for the
spot AC space hello shout out to
those right now I can't wait for uh the
topics that we have today uh real good
with these topics these topics is really
good but what I've been playing
everybody knows that I've been playing
breath of
wild yeah still trying 100% that 100%
it's very hard because that game is
passive so I'm still G to see how you g
to do those those Kuro
seeds I almost finished you are Savage
with those I'm almost finished with
him nice and of course my brother from
another mother the non Agro gamer what's
been going on with you Lord adct talk to
the people uh not much I've been playing
that um I can't remember exactly what
that thing that game's called the what
what's it called lord King the hero
never has been Heroes has been Heroes
has Heroes they game
hard it's it's really
hard so was a little $20 jump off at the
uh it's 39 39 right no it's It's 1999 oh
great great I need that that's what's
up that's what's up been rocking with
that of course Meo been all over the
place um
obviously we got a lot to talk about
Destiny so I dusted that off a little
bit um still been playing Andromeda
still getting a little bit of that in on
on a solo selfish time um slowed down on
Zelda a little bit I think only um what
I was doing I got caught up with some
dungeon or something that was driving me
nuts but now I finally passed it yeah so
I was setting off on my my journey into
some sand
world now bunch of sand area that's
where I'm at now so trying to go the
great Beast over the sand
area I think what happened with me is I
got distracted with like I've been doing
like some fairy hunting just to get the
gear upgraded and stuff like that so I
got Sidetrack with that but other than
that just getting ready and um obviously
we got a good show plans we're gonna
jump right into this so obviously it's
been a huge news week um a lot to catch
up on but the first thing I know me and
Lord addict might want to talk about
that Destiny 2
reveal and how the ords are talking some
Destiny again we got a lot of
information we got two trailers and some
stuff so uh Lord addict talk no gameplay
disgusted we will get
that
do I was going to let you run with it do
your J your arms in here go for
it no but they uh you know obviously
they did the the teaser with with Cade
and then they announced that two days
later which I thought that was kind of
weird to have a teaser to a teaser I I
don't think I've ever I don't think I've
ever seen that but you know we get the
we get the gameplay reveal I think they
said May 15th or something like that so
I mean obviously we knew this was coming
we all knew that Destiny 2 was coming
there's not really even a whole lot to
even really really go into besides you
know speculation because we still we we
know what's going on in in Destiny Tobe
but that's about
it what was your what was let me ask you
a question what was your uh Impressions
like just see let's let's start first
from the beginning let's start with the
initial teaser trailer you know K and
Shop talk like what was your feel I
actually kind of enjoyed that more than
the actual longer trailer because I felt
like you know that they
both said what they wanted to but I I
felt like the second one was more
enjoyable the first one was more
enjoyable because we all love Kade
so I'll jump in on this too I think
let's start with that one out with the
with the teaser um yeah I liked it I
thought that was I thought having Kate
and N Nathan filling was a great choice
I think um I will agree with you I love
the teaser trailer more than the initial
trailer we'll get into the issue trailer
after that um it was just cool it was
just like you know he's talking he's got
the drink going you know shots of fire
he's letting you know how he's doing his
thing and shout out to Hunters Hunters
finally getting their sh their shine
right now I know Lord Sinister Lord SLE
that big hunter guys and they don't feel
that the hunters get love but it's all
about Kade right now I mean he's taking
the shine right now he's doing his thing
so I was really excited about that and
to see all that that Dynamic and then at
the end of that when I think um zala is
like come on K in there you know he's
like I just wanted to drink that I
thought that was funny so yeah I was I
was with that with the with the teaser
trailer where was you at Lord King as
far as just just the teaser trailer when
you first saw when I saw the tza trailer
I said okay I said so these people are
being fooled by these companies yet
again I said here we go again with the
company putting out some CGI crap to get
the masses all stirred up and here we go
CGI crap and they like yo did you see
the new Destiny trailer no I saw CGI
crap
so where's the actual listen this is
what I'm saying we have the technology
now where you can actually did that
ingame engine uh run it with uh K doing
the same ban to the same stuff but run
it ingame engine the reason why they
don't want to do it that way because
it's a whole lot easier to do it CGI now
this is where the let down comes in
because when the actual game is released
and he doesn't look a thing
like what was in the trailer then then
the masses are fooled yet again and you
know what we got to suck it up because
we want the game all right you know
we're gonna buy the game just give us
exactly a endgame trailer so we won't be
disappointed I have any form of let down
when the actual game comes out so let
let me ask you this little Ki May that
you you are clearly not a fan of CGI
trailer oh no I've been burn too much we
do recognize that this is called the
teaser trailer this is okay so okay your
to what's about to happen just warm the
people to your point teaser trailer okay
this is Tuesday coming on uh March 30th
we're gonna release a
trailer uhuh to another teaser now now
now that l king I'm with you and I'm GNA
get into when we talk about I'm so with
you on that now with the initial teaser
trailer I was fine with I'm like you
know what you're getting that out there
you're talking story which is a lot of
people had an issue with vanilla Destiny
saying it had no story and I saw a lot
of people on Twitter social media they
were like yo Destiny okay now where they
lost me is they had to tease the trailer
to another tra now that
i% with
you I kind of if you want my honest
opinion I think this was done at the
last minute I think these leaks were so
severe that they was like we can't I
don't think the first teaser trailer was
ever supposed to be
shown you think they you think they jump
stuff I think they were supposed to they
were supposed to drop this second one
later and what happened was that trailer
was so significant and you know the leak
was so crazy that they're like maybe we
should jump the gun a little bit because
like let's be real here you know there
are certain companies out there that
intentionally leak stuff but Bungie is
not one of these companies they got a
snitch they can't find him they looking
for
him because last year they had way more
leaks and not last year first e the the
first Destiny like the entire the entire
road map for Destiny was leaked like
everything so you know I feel like that
this is one of those things where that
second one was supposed to be the
initial one that was teased for the game
play but you know so many people was
they could have still did the exact same
thing but when it comes down to it I I
guess it's more about timing because you
know they want they want that that
initial you know time they they want
that hype to build up for the game play
and then they want the gamepl to go what
they're going to do obviously is they're
going to show some kind of maybe five
minute trailer at E3 I mean not E3 at in
May and then they're going to show a new
trailer AT3 and then you know they're
going to build up the hype from there
but I mean I I agree with uh uh I agree
with Lord King I mean I think it's
ridiculous that there was a promo to a
promo like I've never that is that is to
an intermission get the
hell I'm so tired of these companies
taking us for fools and a lot of people
that are seeing on Twitter on Instagram
on Facebook they they are run did you
see Destiny no I didn't I didn't see it
because they didn't show it so if you're
gonna talk about what I saw what I saw
was a
CGI
commercial that's it yo it's coming
check it out and I I get that if you
want to do promotion fine put a
disclaimer in the corner put it at the
bottom not actual game play let's keep
it real let's keep it 100% well there's
always no gameplay but here's the thing
no like let me let me let me let me ask
you one question though I see where you
going my question you is this what about
now we live in the age of things like no
man
Sky Mass Effect Andromeda yes sir let's
start with M it's been obviously been
talked a lot so we're in this age where
if you show your bad facial
animations if you show some graphical
flaws and not good FID and breakdown and
we've seen that it could be so damaging
because let's let's be honest again not
that I'm promoting fraud for companies
let's get this is exactly what it sounds
like
all and all s it's easier just to not
show anything and then the game launches
put it on tring to build some hype up
because the gamer is too smart now like
we we're so smart this age of of of
social media and people breaking it down
and did you see the clipping on the foot
found shout out to digital
Foundry yeah exactly and resolution gate
so if you put out your shine is not
right so my question that L Lord Cognito
my question to you you would rather be
fool no I rather this is when Destiny's
case this is what I rather I rather than
you funny it's not about being fool but
I
what I love on story I rather them focus
on story because that's where they lost
the mask like the Casual Mass was like
oh the story and wizard jumps over the
moon and Peter Dinklage is terrible and
oh it was scrapped and so that's all the
vanilla it was us the hardcore that
stuck with it right got to level 30 did
our first rate and was like okay now we
see the potential and then the people
there people never even played Tak King
that knows that you know it was a good
story that they revitalized so with the
teaser trailer 100% I was about it now
where I'm with you is now I feel with
the reveal trailer which we'll get into
now is stalling now I'm with you I now I
feel that okay you s not that you
fooling me but you
stalling sure yeah me okay so I don't
want to I know I know you we GNA get it
to your narrative I know I know yeah my
thing my thing with these guys are you
know and I really love them I love
Bungie you know just the same as
everybody else that loves bunny bunie
I've been with them all the way through
Halo through everything and and it's
fantastic okay um I believe that there's
an old Dogma that's inside these
companies and they feel that they have
to fool the public and we're in a day
and age where you don't have to you can
put down at the bottom because Microsoft
does this
actual ingame
engine okay
and but not but not initially
there's
anytime anytime that they put out a
couple of games it says actual game
engine and if they put out a lot of the
Gears of War if you look in the corner
um you know and they show they it says
uh not actual and you know um and it's
fine I have no problem with CGI CGI has
it moments in games and CGI has its
moments for teasers and trailers and
stuff like that but the narrative
shouldn't be did you see Destiny 2 The
Narrative should be did you see the uh
the the CGI
video for Destiny 2 it was a nice CGI
video it was very funny it was very
witty and it gave you uh Insight on
cabal hitting because everybody wanted
the cabal so we got what we wanted and
every it's fine that's great
don't tell me you saw Destiny 2 CU you
didn't that's you didn't see
it we're talking technicality waiting
for that game play engine reveal so okay
so so do you really think that people
feel that they saw Destiny what
was listen I was going back and forth
with people on Facebook on Instagram
talking about yeah man that Destiny 2
look amazing what what what he said yo
they Ste their Graphics up this year
what he said did you see them shooting
in the background it looks so real
what like shut up like you didn't see
anything so so your your point is more
that you don't feel that the consumer is
smart enough to discern it that these
are not real gam playay and that this is
actually what they're going to get come
September exactly listen we're a small
segment of the population that actually
are smart enough or we've been beaten
hard enough this is what it is we've
been beaten so much by these companies
to know the difference we've been hit
don't don't yeah like a dog don't don't
do that in the corner we see it okay we
won't do that we know we've been beaten
by Final Fantasy the ultimate
rules remember the Dance Floor never
forget it they told
you and we never got that we're still
looking for that for this day M2 still
looking for that to this day I feel you
but I think here here's the I I know
what you're going I think in past
Generations like especially the one
before 100% agree I think where it is
now is the consum to me is so smart the
gameer now is so smart like remember
when Watch Dogs try to pull it and like
dudes are now coming up with saying they
be like downgrade confirmed like that's
the new thing now like people are so
aware of the Foolery that they know they
can't get away with it so I was actually
impressed when they said okay Gameplay
trailer is going to be they actually
said Gameplay trailer will be May 18th
or whatever whatever but I get switch
that narrative too because they said the
Gameplay trailer would be that Friday
and switch that all the way to may see
because this the first time I'm hearing
that it's May I just suck my teeth to
that he's like whatever yeah whatever I
hear you I hear so now and get into the
uh the second part of the um you know
the trailer out the the the movie
CGI over the reveal um so we got the
tower
destroyed we've got um obviously the
Guardians on the run like how do we feel
about just the direction like of where
Destiny is going do we like it do we
like them on run do we see the the
possibilities also we wanted to talk
about the um expansions you know
obviously one should be the Osiris would
be the first one there's also Le shout
out to Lord Bri rabert he just put it
out on good morning Guardians um it
looks like def definitely the Osiris
expansion one DLC will be released
Winter so we're looking at December
already from a quick turnaround from
September with the first DLC and then
spring of uh 2018 will be that um
Rasputin DLC so what do we feel about
that whole I mean just the direction of
the story these expansions how are we
feeling about
everything uh Lord um uh adct you wanna
ad is good you can you can go first Lord
King I Feel fantastic about I've always
liked anything that Bungie has dropped
as far as the dlc's go I'm not gonna lie
they are in order with other
MMOs uh World of Warcraft does the same
thing and I think actually Bungie gets
bashed a little bit too much for their
DLC content that they do drop and I
think they drop more than Norm when it
comes to MMOs usually MMOs goes years
without dropping a new DLC and then they
hype it up and you comes out I I thought
they did a fantastic job with all the
DLC that they dropped I thought the
content was uh fruitful because it kept
us playing for hours I thought it was
impactful as far as some of the
graphical upgrades that no one talked
about but was going on um uh and the
frame rate issues were actually fixed so
Bungie does a lot of things on the
behind the scenes uh for the MMO and I
can't wait for the new uh DLC Direction
I think they're gonna do a fantastic job
oh I forgot one other question I want to
add in with that l king is um what would
be one of your obviously you're a huge
division guy so my question is what
would be one of the features that you
really would love to see Destiny to
implement that could get you excited
potentially I'm excited from everything
um aspect of it because they're starting
a new they they saw what they did wrong
and they and they say okay well you know
we're not going to bring over these
weapons and stuff like that so that
gives them a chance to retool Old
favorites and bring back old favorites
how they initially intended it to be uh
because they did the balancing issues
and stuff like that so Destiny one was a
giant beta and I believe Destiny 2
is that's a good point that's actually a
good point um look jumping I I was going
to jump in on
this I mean I I like you know we've
always wanted the something with the
cabal because the cabal's such a
fantastic faction that they ain't really
ever went into and this is the first
time they've ever I mean in the lore
cabal have machines that can move whole
planets you know they're they're very
very 300 civilization you know Spartans
they they their philosophy is if you go
to war you banished until you win that
war yeah yeah you can't come back home
until you win you do what you we set you
out to do that's the cabal Mantra
like I'm sorry so I mean we just have to
see how they actually do it like I'm not
really have a problem with what they're
going into I like the the scenario that
Destiny 2's starting it's just I'm a
little iffy on what they're going to do
with Destiny 2 as a
whole it's just like I don't know what
they're gonna try to fix what they're
gonna try to you know you talking about
from a mechanic G standpoint I don't
know like some some of these companies
when they have a successful first one
they try to bring more of a they try to
bring more people in but they end up
pushing more people out okay so you're
worried about
like
casualized narratively I'm I'm really
cool with it I thought they did a great
job explaining why things don't go forth
by just blowing up the fall that was I
did like that they did put the they made
a cannon of why it's being destroyed and
not just it's gone it's just gone you
know that's it so that was cool um
obviously y you know Lords know I'm a
huge fan of cabal those are my peoples I
don't feel they get enough enough love
and um you know narratively why I think
that was cool that you know they like
look you you got involved with our
business in the dread lot we was about
to handle or on our own we don't need
you you know and they came when they
came to our crib and got us out of there
now me perfect purposely I like I would
love I know this gonna Sound fire I'm in
a lot of back backlash for this I would
love for them to just kill the speaker I
would love dog had came in there and
just you know they put the knife behind
and you see his lifeless body go limp
it's in on a throne like kind of like
how Lord King has the
the I will go
in the throne chilling by it and I just
I hate to speak so I think he's a
charlatan you know my man is Osiris you
know I think he's a false prophet he's
been misleading us but that's just my my
feeling so narratively I love this I
love that the tower destroy and I did
not see the speaker so I'm hoping he's
out of it so that's number one um as far
as the I think you're really really
reaching that that not going
anywhere we don't know we didn't
see we don't know I hope I hope the age
of trium was the last time I hear that
voice you know what this week I'm going
to put on age of Triumph um with us baby
I'm going to jump in there I'm gonna
give I I paid for exposed I paid for the
game and um I played and I supported
them all the way through I don't care
how jaded I am with what they said
they're G to do later on um what I need
to do is continue to support the the
franchise that I bet money on when you
put your money
there you bet on it and when you support
every DLC that comes out you're better
now now all your chips is in the middle
of the table so just because the cards
that are dealt aren't the Cs that you
wanted to see that doesn't mean that you
fold and you know pack up your tent get
up so what you back it's been fun I I
have to admit like just dusting it off
doing cotay and then like you guys are
the cro to vet so I know nothing like I
I ran it halfway through I know nothing
but you guys carrying me right right and
nothing but from a cheating perspective
all right stand over there
Cognito that was like my first raid I
was very underleveled you know mean so
was shout out to you Lord sent to Lord
King you guys grabed me up and said no
we got you we G we gonna get you through
your first rate you know yeah now the
thing that's funny doing it now is
they've made subtle changes where they
down the hustles so oh yeah that's yeah
like now it's like certain things but
guys used to do the cheat to go over the
bridge you can't do that no more like
you have to do things legitimately so in
that sense it felt new you know I mean
and shout out to L we had a funny rate
Lord addict can tell you it was one of
the most hilarious I saw it and I really
wanted to say I don't know Lord adct if
you saw me put that love on that video
that you
posted I put that love up there for you
man that game that was running around
with according to Lord I wouldn't doing
jack
[__] well he's not a lord
so stop with all that you should ask
lordo about that
conversation let's stop saying Lord in
front of his name na is he's just who he
is he's a nice God bless him you
know even a shadow five ofum that's no
his brother is a shadow five
Chow remember he's a
subsidary let's let's let's keep it a
100 he's a
subsidiary uh he said he's subid we
don't we don't believe in nepotism so
you're not
Club he threw the Jersey on he threw the
Jersey he can look he can look at you
know he the water boy he the water boy
was the keep it 100
all right anyway but you was doing your
thing yeah I was killing everybody don't
yes he he went down there he killed the
OG he went in the room he killed the the
Wizards he yo he had this yo I swear I
was watching the game play and I was
like look at at it go you know you
didn't hear the G the party chat but the
whole time I was like Neil where are you
why am I the over
myself yes
I that you got baby your loot game right
they blessed you it was nice they got
the ex Elemental primaries back and
stuff like that so it's good but not to
get too off know AG of Triumph is there
I just wanted to finish one last sorry I
had to jump in it no that's f f it it
definitely was worth talking about um
what I wanted to get into was just one
thing as far as like a want obviously I
said my narrative want but my game
playay want and I'm a shout out shout
out to
Division I don't think it's gonna happen
but if they're not going to give us four
player fire teams like how you know
division has which I really like then
what I meant and I speak to shout out
the Lord dizzy like I
need like six person patrols or four to
six that's reach I think that's pretty
like like the thing is if if it was hard
if you couldn't do that right now then
I'll be like you know that's ridiculous
but us as a destiny Community we have
found cheeses to make this possible so
they just
tricks in the cter oric tricks in the um
what's the archons voyage all right get
your man and message him and then see if
we can bring in some we could be in the
same instance like we need to one thing
that division does very well you know
besides shout the Lord no he's gonna say
youu are an item organization yes we
know
that but outside of that what I love
about division is if your man is in the
map you go to where he's at you know I
mean and and it's an inst an automatic
instance you're there especially Patrol
spaces like it should be no reason why
four the six players of channel five we
can't or at least make like six player
patrols and if if the story is what it
is the towers destroyed we're out in the
barren Earth setting up Outpost it's
it's made for this like it's mechanics
like that that make the division more
you know Team friendly
because it's it's reasons like that that
you in the dark Zone and you see like
eight eight people come up on you
because they was e for them people to
get together
yeah that's what I'm talk about let's
talk that division baby oh man we got
him
started
D I will always give credit what credit
is do and I always felt that division
did that very well and those are things
that I back my mind like that's I better
steal that that's really good you know I
really felt that that was a good good
property but um yeah I'm excited I'm
excited for Destiny 2 our trailer
hopefully we get some gameplay for Lord
Kings so we can calm him down
[Music]
falling for it I know it's coming and as
soon as it does you know arrive then you
know it'll quell a lot of the the
rhetoric that's you know that's going on
right now but it's it's it's going to be
good I I believe so I don't believe that
they're gonna screw it up dual Welden I
hope it's
there like speaking of which shout out
to those new Kabal enemy types like the
um the dual wield and sword person and
then um like I said like the red
and stuff like so I like I like like
those little like wilderbeast things
that was attacking so I like that they
they doing different stuff like that oh
real quick what do you guys shout a l
this question for you
specifically what do you feel about like
like cabal ra that potential that could
be you had some ideas we talked offline
before
fantastic I choked up I want I want to
see the home world I want the home world
I want I want to see how how the cabal
live and get
down for what they're saying from the
GameStop leag Lord King is they're
trying to say that like they destroyed
us we're scattered and like we have to
go to different parts of the Galaxy to
round up other Guardians and almost like
we've even lost our powers is what
they're saying too like we they're gonna
retool yeah that's what I think yep so
um I don't know if we'll get to go to
the whole
world oh I hope you know me I I love
that there I mean okay it and this is
what I give a Credence to what you're
talking about I think it's very credible
um I believe if if if as a
strategy and you know the cabal are
strategic and everything that they do
100% I believe the strategy is to go and
cut the head off the snake right so you
go in you kill a speaker
and and blow up the
Tower and the forge I honestly believe
that that would be the strategy to do so
so and they probably thought that uh
remember when they blew up the tower
they were going for all the heads they
were going for you know the head of the
hunters the head of theal attack they
started right where they were exactly
shout out the little dizzy he's like
kill the speaker I'm with him he's in
C yeah so got to go he's if you think
it's F like what's funny is the Vex is
tried to do this the the high's tried to
do this to fall in you know there
there's been consistent attacking on
this tower that they've said for like
the past thousand years and it's like
the cabal was like I'm done like I I'm
blowing [__]
up yeah I love it I think this is the
first time in the Lord that the cabal
has actually been in this galaxy like
this like you know
now you were saying Lord addict in
reference um now you're back as far as
the um the raid like you mentioned some
mechanics like if you want like a war
like an ongoing War during the raid like
tell me tell me your raid hopes that you
would think about the way I would want
the raid to be and obviously this is
pure speculation highly doubt any of
this would happen but I think it'd be
cool if like you know the first raid out
of Destiny 2 is during the war and'll be
like you know like um you know and all
them are fighting outside the walls of
where if we're on like a cabal
leadership or something or you know a
cabal drop ship that's dropped down or
something of that like you know the the
ship that they brought in to attack us
with and like some of the parts in the
right not all of the parts is like
interacting with them or lasting long
enough for them to do something to
interact with what we're
doing okay I see what you're saying I
see what you're saying yeah that would
be cool I mean that whole backdrop of a
destroy or you know destroyed City would
be kind of crazy and I want to see what
Gaul can do he's kind of he's kind of
got that like um reminds like a little
bit little planet Hulk beastin going on
Lord disy does have Lord dizzy does have
a a point there we we did kind of like
just Dro in and I don't even think the
cabal really did anything to us we just
started killing people on the dreadn so
that
proba we was in their business like we
should have let them handle it they
remember they crashed their ship into
Oro ship to go handle it and they
brought the shield brothers and a whole
buch and here we are involving oursel in
cabal
business should have mind our
business like Gary is not about
that I love that Kate calls him Gary I
think that was
hilarious he was like
Gary dude when he was trying to guess
his name and he was like something with
a G I just lost it after that you know
what I thought I I thought thought that
they did it without the hunter at
first because they had the side show for
the hunter when he was sitting at the
bar and I thought that that that teaser
was separate right I thought they did
that separate and I thought they did it
with the
Titan next and and it didn't go over
well and I think they added the hunter
to give the comedy relief to it yeah I
think so I think I think you nailed it I
think what they realized is yes Destiny
is this like this space Epic with all
this supposedly great lore buried in
grimoire and what I think one of the
strength of the T King was like Nathan
fillian saying like look okay we don't
have to take this so serious let's add a
little comic relief to it and honestly I
think me and Lord adct had this
discussion I think Cade speaks to the
player because if if he you heard his
thing he's like and more Loot and
everybody's like yeah loot like you know
what saying they blew up his stuff they
blew up your stuff and people were just
dogging on uh on know what what's his
what's the Titan Savala yeah I always I
always mispronounce his name but I
actually liked his speech too I like you
know Lord King Lord saala is our man um
from from The Wire that's Lieutenant
Daniels that's Lance Reit oh yeah yeah
yeah I know yeah I like I like I like he
just walked around he's like
using and what was funny is it's like
him and K are the exact opposite of each
other he's like I know you guys looking
to me for for support but this isn't
something that I could do by myself and
Kate's like if you don't F if you if
you're not out there I'll kill you
myself yeah and in the back a lot a
couple of uh people on Twitter actually
freeze framed hit during his speech if
you take a a screenshot you'd see Lord
saladan in the back you see little
Shacks you got Zur in the back you know
so I thought that was interesting too
that Salin came through you know what
I'm saying to help out and it was all
hands on that kind of a thing so it's
going to be crazy man we got we got a
lot of stuff going they got faction they
got so much potential so definitely
definitely excited and um it's going to
be interesting diz's in there he's like
Kade is to Destiny with uh Deadpool is
to Mar yeah I think he nailed it yeah
dizzy you're on it I think's like all
Spiderman you know the witty banter
let's not let's not discredit Spiderman
and give all this uh praise to Deadpool
with being so witty Spiderman was do
first and he was doing it in the form um
you just like the the crude and crass
Behavior and the vulgarness of Deadpool
that's the only thing that you like so
let's let's stop being so witty
Spider-Man's been doing it let's not get
into a Marvel conversation we gonna get
into a Marvel
conversation that's coming so you're not
gonna shut that down my Spiderman
love we are excited about Destiny 2 the
Lords of ready it's good to be talking
Destiny Lord King we gonna get you in
these raids man we gonna get you going
on some major Triumph yeah we need
someone else that can run a sword man me
and S can't do it all shout out to
lordal they killing the break
down lord yo stop that right there shout
out to Neil no before we move on though
with this topic like L Lord Lord King I
kid you not like the reason you saw that
game play is because he was running that
mouth that I kep recording the game play
to show like dude you ain't killing
nothing like you just by the time he
gets there everyone already dead you
know what it is he's been he room allows
this
individual to get under his skin the
Lord addict allows this individual to do
this to him on numerous occasion you can
ask Lord Lord Cognito that time I was
going in on him I was like I record it I
record it I show you he's like he's like
and then we were talking about the ogre
part okay let's talk about that last
part it's like what what happened to the
ogre part you just messed up on Neil why
we changing the the gopost shout out to
De he's channel five member who is
extremely he's a
channary and for people in the chat for
people in the chat the those raids will
end your
friendship yes croa will end your
friendship especially now with how you
can't kind of chese your weight and
everything has to be done right everyone
kind of has to hold their weight a
little bit more so yeah I I I would
agree but U moving on on that note go
on look you you want to jump in with
your your your transition or we you felt
you touched it when we go to uh the
other topic oh let let's let's let's go
on to uh the strategy um okay we GNA
jump into strategy well before that
before we do that yeah okay let's jump
right into scor okay cool you know right
now obviously there's a lot of news
Outlet shout out to Gordon shout out to
window Central and those guys um the the
rumors coming down the pipeline that uh
Scorpio reveal will be uh revealed this
week coming that it's going to be a
major news Outlet so we don't know which
one that could be if it's like an [__] or
any of those things there's also been Le
or that be lit major news Outlet imagine
if that was on I would lose my [__] I
think I think it's going to be on a real
major I don't want to say IGN is not
real IGN I've been told that it's going
to be a tech website it's not it's not
gonna be GameStop it's going to be a
tech website then they might bound up
with digital Foundry since digital
Foundry was doing such the exposing of
them last well you can say last
generation because that's last
generation um I I I really believe with
that PlayStation 4 and digital Foundry
wasn't riding with the PlayStation 4
they was just stating the obvious people
will like to say that digital Foundry
has a certain affinity for PlayStation 4
they don't they just have Affinity they
just go by facts that's it the facts
yeah and it was clear that in in initial
beginning of the
generation playst multiplats were
Superior from a graphical standpoint
from a resolution standpoint or you know
from is instances from a frame rate
standpoint so that I agree in that sense
I think that have a better G become
glorified though like at this generation
kind of brought them to the Forefront
and showing disparity between console
comparison what do you think about that
okay oh I I thought that digital Foundry
and I found them by habit I thought they
are fantastic because they answer a lot
of my questions my questions is are
these guys
lying I just need to know are they lying
to me that's it I don't care how you put
on the makeup on your face just let me
know do you look like this under the
makeup or if you don't so CGI like I
said they'll tell you no this is a CGI
cut scene it's at 30 frames per second
this is no doesn't matter let's get the
game play oh they have a fluctuating
adaptive vsync they and they break it
down so that the Layman can understand
that's why I love digital Foundry and I
believe that they they might go with
them just to expose just to show you
that we're at true 4K gaming imagine if
they do go through digital Foundry sorry
to interrupt you like imagine like that
would be crazy that's big that's really
well that that would be the ultimate
confidence because yep that would mean
that that's the number one site that's
been [__] on you for the past three
years exactly especially showing that
your you know versions are you
know and that would just be ultimate
confidence if they would show them now
the only thing is they were wait aren't
they like they're still European Outlet
right because they're associated with uh
Euro gamer yes so I'm I'm as much as I
would love that and I would be like
amazing if they did that I'm not sure
because you think maybe they might want
to bring it out to a US News Outlet
first might go the Europe brout because
remember we're lagging behind in Europe
and if we can get the Europe mind share
the European mind share then we can
actually uh that that' be
cool yeah they're behind over there so
they definitely you know would do that
now as far as um they're also saying in
this report that there will be revealing
specs
Yep they're listing games they're saying
um a lot of the first party titles as
far as from a four is a seven crack
which we kind of expect it down we
expect it stated Decay to so all the
first party stuff we kind of expected
but then they kind of threw in the loop
with some um Call of Duty FIFA Madden
she being a Scorpio kind of infused
title Battlefront to Red Dead Redemption
to I mean that's the perfect way to
combat someone getting all the marketing
deals for the first part uh for the
third party deals is I mean it's not the
in all Beall regardless what you come
out if they got exclusive content that's
still G to overshot your Superior
version but it's a way to really put a
dent off of it yeah definitely
definitely I mean I think what they made
the approach that Phil and these guys
may be taking is saying okay because
again if you look on Twitter and you
look on you know with Aaron uh Greenberg
and the marketing guys you know the
first thing he'll say like when Destiny
2 came out and we all know that Destiny
to the marketing is with Sony and
exclusive with Sony so I thought it was
interesting that the first thing this
guy brought out and gyberg is like I
can't wait to see how that's going to
look on on Scorpio you know and then I
believe it was uh what was the next
thing was it Battlefront when they
announced Battlefront um Lord addict
yeah how do you guys feel about that you
think that's like you think they're just
trying to damage control through like
really smart marketing and
PR I have my theory but l k you want to
jump
in um no no go ahead attack
it yeah my theory is that again we know
for a fact you know right now from a
game from an exclusive standpoint you
know that right now M Microsoft and Xbox
One is is pretty hurting as far they're
behind you know Sony's had a great first
half of the Year these amazing exclus
and they keep coming you know Persona 5
just dropped you know you got the MLB
dropped you know the list goes on and on
with these great exclusive titles for
the first half of the year so I think to
your point Lord addict what they may be
saying to themselves is saying okay
we're not going to win that but how we
can do it is we can change the narrative
and kind of do what Sony did to them in
the initial part of the generation which
was okay we all are multiplats run
better look better therefore we have the
definitive version of set game so even
though you may have the marketing rights
they may say hey Xbox One shows the true
you know 4K HDR now will that be enough
time time will tell but I will say this
just depends on how different the the
the multiplats are if they're
significant if there significant
difference that's how you turn the media
against competition if there's a like a
game like what is it shadow of wall was
once they announced they put you notice
they putting their marketing and their
name behind Destiny 2 they threw their
name behind so you know Battlefront now
we're hearing Red Dead and you know all
these games so again if the jump is as
significant as what people are saying
and I've got some tea leaves going on
you know and people are telling me like
when you see this stuff your face is g
to melt so I'm trying not to B too much
you to the
hype but you know for me personally and
shout out to Lord dizzy we've had this
conversation a thousand times you know
listen the multiplats fantastic I'm all
about that what I as far as I'm looking
better
I just need those exclusives in
conjunction they throw that in
conjunction and show some stuff that is
only on the platform or they've been
working on then to me you KN get out the
park and is that's I think right now is
what is sorely lacking but that's what I
got on it what you gotta look at oh okay
I'm in the same vein as you um I thought
Microsoft backed their self into a
corner when they stopped funding uh a
lot of their project
or maybe they are at the point where
they're tired of revealing stuff and I
think that's a possibility too that
they're that you know a lot of people
you know they keep saying well Microsoft
did this Microsoft did that Phil Spencer
seems like he don't do [__] that
Microsoft normally does right so he's
his own deal he's not he's not getting
those marketing deal he doesn't care
about marketing deal he he said he said
I don't like third party marketing deals
and since then we've seen marketing
deals but not to the extent the T time
exclusive was way before Phil came in
that that was in stone already it it you
know maybe it's like it's like you know
me and Lord Cognito and Lord King said
in the past maybe in the next like year
or two we'll actually see moves that
Phil actually made himself from the
start and not something that was you
know already in motion scalebound was
already in motion all these games that
are cancelled wasn't even him that
started the funding for it it was just
Phil trying to keep the momentum for
those games going am I giving him excuse
for canceling these games of course not
you know scalebound that you know all
these games have their own problems that
they were had to cancel we will never
know why some of these games were
cancelled but I feel if you saw scale
bound like I did you saw the frame rate
problems and stuff like that you saw
exactly what I saw so we was saying when
we was watching these games I hope they
clear that up mayy Phil said the same
thing and these people weren't clearing
it up and he said you know what I'm not
putting it out
yeah what's funny is uh that joke going
around every time that near automatic
game comes up it's was like look
Microsoft funded
that they Savage they
Savage it's gonna be interesting yeah
well you know what I noticed that uh
when it comes to software software takes
it's like a presidential term takes four
to eight years for you actually see
something uh and when it comes to a
hardware type of thing it's more
immediate it's more to the people's more
in Congress uh not mean not Congress
it's more as your Senator and stuff like
that so that stuff happens immediately
so Phil is actually able to say
immediately slim that box down put out a
Xbox slim want a 4K in this and boom
that's done you know you can go to
production you can get that run up let's
get that out as far as my system goes
this is we all know this is a Phil
system so the way Phil's vision is and
maybe Phil's vision is definitively I
want our uh own games because remember
before the best games played on
Xbox now when the narrative changes that
the the multiplats run better on the
Playstation system we was thrown back we
was like what it did we was at a loss
for that we didn't understand that that
was foring to us because we came up with
Madden Rand better on Xbox this ran
better on Xbox so now it's like it's
running better on PlayStation that was a
hard pill to swallow oh absolutely
absolutely I mean I think I also wanted
to throw this point in with this whole
thing if this rumor is true is that you
know one I think it's smart to actually
do a reveal you know if hopefully if
they can announce a reveal is coming
before E3 this way E3 can be focused
completely on the games you know because
I was doing the history on it it was May
I believe it was May of um 2013 is when
the Xbox One reveal happened remember
even though it was disaster because they
were talking TV TV and the the whole DRM
stuff and people got all out of shape I
happen to like it I'm sorry I was in a
minority listen I'm with you too it's
it's one of those things they actually
did a survey just recently um forgot the
uh the publication I want to get proper
credit but they just did a survey about
right now do people care about digital
versus the physical and I was shock
people's the people who wanted the
physical still were in the lead as far
as from a from a vote standpoint me
personally I'm with you looking like I'm
pretty much 100% digital you
know yeah like it's like what we holding
on to and then even a lot of these games
that you the physical disc are online
only games like you know OverWatch
Destiny so the disc means nothing ask
question I want to ask you this question
right
I'm this is for those idiots and I hope
yall are inside the room chat right now
you
idiots all you idiots that was talking
about DRM always online I'm not about
that life okay you always online now you
idiot system is always on you're always
hooked up to WiFi you're always hooked
up to the Internet why because you're
always linked up to YouTube you're
always linked up to
something very rarely everybody's Xbox
is sitting off and not linked online if
you ever went to your friend's house and
you turned on his Xbox and he had no
connect to the internet you'll look at
him like what's going on here exactly I
mean it's we're so integrated with it
you're right so what was the problem
because people want physical discs
unfortunately not the physical part
about it they talking about the arm you
always got to check and remember that
that was the the nail in the coff right
in conjunction with connect everybody
had they you know they third eye open
might be in their house oh God but they
W it was bad too it was bad like the
Microsoft got hit from different angles
they got hit from the the you know the
the no use games and not to mention Sony
making hilarious YouTube videos on the
side sh fire diss tracks and then you
got not only are they getting hit by the
used game policy they're getting hit by
the always on thing they're getting hit
by the the
um they're getting hit by the uh the
always on and what was the thing we were
just talking about physical digit the
physical used de games that it wouldn't
play Ed games the connect the connect I
think it yeah I think it would have been
better that but it's just like that
reveal just hurt them so much that it
would have dethroned anyone and tvt and
that's why I want to I want to make the
statement too because I know a lot of
the XBox guys really down on Xbox and
you know I Gotta Give Phil this he
inherited a [__] child at Birth far
Xbox not the correct term
uh the iron Lords podcast well
retardation that's not the politically
correct term
mentally challenged child challeng yes
mentally challeng child it was it was a
lot of um lot of the debilitation that
had to happen you know Rehabilitation
that had to happen when when uh our man
Phil Spencer join team and I would go as
far as saying that he had a child on
life
support pretty much I mean for it to
even be respectable and talk about
talked about now you know as just even
you know compe and turn it around and
winning npds a couple of times here and
there you know it to me is amazing how
he changed the
messaging yeah go for it I'll give you a
caveat and people are not talking about
this enough the PlayStation 4 is on a
unprecedented uh run this is this is
let's take them out of the equation
right let's say
PlayStation existed good point this Xbox
One
is on Pace to out paace the
3606 which was the highly uh successful
system from the last
generation so the numbers that the the
Xbox One is putting up is better than
the 360 numbers but we're looking at it
as a failure because the PlayStation 4
is selling at a rate that doesn't make
any sense exactly and he just nailed it
l nailed it and that's the thing
unfortunately a lot of Xbox Fanboys a
lot of people who are on side of Xbox
are not seeing the big picture from a
corporation standpoint they are
outpacing the 360 which was their most
successful system so they're doing well
it's just that from a fanboy standpoint
you're looking at the other dudes and
you're like damn we going you know we
doing Platinum they got they going
Diamond yes you like still going
Platinum it's nothing wrong with that
just we 50 cent They Eminem it's exactly
it's very
got be comfortable with
that I'll be 50 I'll be 50 now think
about it this way also at the end of the
road right when Eminem was all said and
done he's all washed up in the corner
um going all right power is on listen
the system is coming Scorpio's
coming also I want I want to jump in on
that too King because this is my theory
and again shout out to Dizzy's in the
chat shout out to Lord dizzy like um my
theory is people like well you know
what's Microsoft going to do like how
are they just you know getting it behind
kick as far as exclusive because if you
look at the narrative right now if you
go to all the major news outlets it's
you know it's Doom and Gloom you know
it's just like you know oh you don't
think anything Microsoft can do and blah
blah blah you know one thing people
forget is me and L King we were around
for OG Xbox yep right we thought that
that machine and their Vision was
fantastic like hard drive in the Box the
first to do ethernet in the system you
know what I mean like they had a lot of
things we like okay but it came out
during the time of PlayStation 2 right
and Playstation 2 was just like it was
no stop in that movement it was no stop
in that movie when no matter when you
came out so what I felt which was smart
is Microsoft dictated and ended the
Generation by saying okay you know what
360 we're coming out right now and
everybody was like whoa they coming out
with a new system already and to me this
is a kind of Replay in my mind is what
they're doing with Scorpio they like
look the damage is done with matrick
this is Phil may be saying this is my
baby right let's dictate the new
generation now with Scorpio you see what
I'm saying yeah and do it the way it
should have been done and we start the
trend you see what I'm saying because if
you remember 360 came out a year before
PS3 they had that year to them not to
themselves but you know what I'm saying
from a standpoint of taking all the
momentum away from the PS too it was
Superior from a graphic standpoint
points look better everything looked
better then kind of Sony kind of forced
the hand to kind of speed up come up
with PS3 with the cell processor and you
know all that stuff but um the fact of
the matter remains is that Microsoft
dictated the start of that generation so
I think they may be doing that I don't
know I want to know what Lord adct
thinks about my theory in reference to
that
I I have mixed I I kind of don't think
that they're going to start another
gener I mean part of me thinks that you
know the right the writing is on the
wall you know it's like I was telling
Lord Cognito about a week ago the only
thing that could even remotely there's a
couple things that could you know get
Microsoft out of the ditch and you know
kind of do the the PS3 of last
generation just barely catch up by the
end of the generation I don't think
they'll pass PlayStation forever but you
know they can neither have like bomb
couple bomb franchise that you know
really push out Xbox One units or they
have that like Halo 2 of the original
Xbox that just blows up so fast that
everyone buys an Xbox one because of
what you know we've talked about that on
iron Lord's podcast they just don't have
they don't have the studios we know
every Studio that they have that that we
are knowledgeable every first party
Studio we know all of them are making
and you know for the next two to three
years so I just I don't see them just
redoing another generation I I for some
reason you don't see as a refresh you
see this more because yeah they're doing
it's Xbox One regardless you know we
there's I've been told that you know
it's going to be called Xbox One
something so I feel like they're keeping
it in the family now will they do
iterations like this and never have
another generation every couple years I
think that's more that's more plausible
than them just starting another
generation who knows Microsoft might
change the way Generations happen with
with the Xbox One almost like a midc
console refreshes what you going
with well we're at a stage in our
Evolution as uh humans that we want
everything faster quicker stronger more
powerful uh shout out to the Samsung
Galaxy 8
um oh yeah and the the the the midseason
refresh uh it's happening with TV
shows it's happening with everything in
our life we are starting to get things
in bik siiz chunks and we're taking it
how we want to take it right and Phil
looked at it and he said okay just like
Lord addict said it's a wash we're not
catching up to these guys you're not
catching up exactly and it's a part of
both of what both of you have said uh L
we have saw we were around long enough
to
see Microsoft say okay we're dictating
policy we're writing policy it starts
now when Scorpio drops the Next
Generation Starts Now
Sony uh sorry for the pro and you guys
have purchased a pro like myself I
purchased two of them um it's been a
disappointment okay and from a from a
hardwood standpoint from a hardware
standpoint from the software standpoint
there's no software that actually
supports the the thing it's from a
standpoint of the whole thing is is a
farce no no Horizon zero Dawn left no no
I don't have it I don't got the game why
because it said that it's it's
graphically enhanced yes yes it's not
compelling enough for me to believe that
lie
um I I listen I I know Sony I know Sony
very well I've been burnt by Sony for so
long I understand Bull and I can see it
from a mile away I mean if it's facts
it's facts if it's not it's not so what
what do you feel is the farce with the
pro I just I just want to clarify for
the the PlayStation 4K from the 4K it's
not a 4K system right okay so you feel
it's kind of a half Mees you talking
about like checkerboard rendering that
kind of stuff and not enough HDR 4 it's
a lie it's a lie from from from when you
pick up the box and you read the box
it's a lot so no no HDR mandatory you
know listen the Xbox uh 1 s is more of a
4K system than that Pro and it's cheaper
uh shout out to Microsoft go get that
um Savage both both you guys were right
and on the nail hit the the nail on the
head adct in his perspective of Phil
said scrap this we won't catch up your
perspective in Microsoft saying that
we're going to dictate policy
we will tell you when the next
Generation comes out and the Next
Generation starts with
Scorpio and from that point we wipe the
Slate clean and we start a new you get a
new mind chare you you you have the
narrative that these guys have to catch
up and you put the pressure back on son
okay so what do you say I don't want to
go I know we're going off because I know
it's part of your your topic too as far
as Sony strategy but I wanted to say
what do you say to the to the Sony guys
that
say but you guys have no game you know
it doesn't matter you know because what
I'm seeing is a shift I'm seeing that
the XBox guys in the beginning of the
generation were like hey that we got
1080p is nice but we got the 720 smooth
rate and we got games whereas now
exactly Sony's like well your multiplats
run like crap and your 900p and yada y y
so now that the tables are reversing the
narratives may be changing and you have
Sony guys saying well look you guys have
no exclusives you know I mean and now
we're saying we got 4kd we got the P we
got the definitive version so what are
you saying to the guys that say that you
guys still don't have any games it's
just Multiplex kudos to you you're
ripping the dead
system I'm take the Nar yeah I'mma take
the narrative and I'mma take it and do
exactly what Sony does Sony always flips
it they and it's this has been their
Mantra forever
whenever you go left we going to go
right and doing okay we got more power
okay uh y'all got games okay so what now
we have more power we got
games no brother you don't they moving
the go post they moving go post King you
don't get it both ways this is when
Microsoft destroys that Narrative of we
got
games this is how we play anywhere we
have more games than you because we can
play all our 360 games period so from
the standpoint of games you don't have
more games our backlog and catalog shows
you that we have more games we can play
on any platform that has Windows 10
devices right but what about they're
going to say first party exclusive that
they quality of the first P exclusives
nice that's that's nice you're repping a
dead sister it's that you know why
because it's last generation why is it
last generation it's happening now
Microsoft said so it's dead we're on to
Scorpio we we y lost and they can say y
lost we beat you here first we're
starting over fresh we're not even
talking about that old stuff and that's
what we we're not talking about last
year they G move the go say that's last
year that's last year stuff what are you
talking about what what are you doing in
4k right now we we have this Stu over
here where at I wouldn't be interested
if I could s attack you know Microsoft
should have did Microsoft should have
did a video where how you play a 4K
movie on Xbox open the tray and put it
in boom shots fir just play it right
back see they don't have me in marketing
if they had me in marketing they would
never
lose just put the 4K and how can you
play a 4K movie on Playstation Pro or
PlayStation 4 or Playstation slim you
got mad PlayStations
how can you play a 4K movie on
Playstation you
can't well they have that advantage of
4K BL you know it's going to be
interesting to see how um how Phil and
these guys approach it what what's the
Xbox narrative you know because again I
think we just been seeing you know shout
out to Lord we just been seeing um
little hints from the marketing team of
saying you know which version and um you
know how how great the Scorpio version
is going to look you know Shadow War
Destiny 2 Battlefront that kind of stuff
so it looks like they are leaning to
some of the stuff that you are saying
Lord King as far as promoting that power
and you know seeing how they dictate why
not why not go out there and swing that
big baseball bat if you don't if you got
it you got it swing it baby show them be
bar Bor step up to the plate knock a
home run out every time we shall see
this week the rumors are tingling
they're saying we should get a Scorpio
revealed or at minimum maybe some specs
and should be interesting to see what
happens when it happens
though what is going be when they show
up to the party
though doubt it's gonna be interesting
so as we on that note we're GNA move
forward and we're going to get into the
um Lord King's topic so you want to talk
about let talking from the from the Sony
perspective now we've talked from the
Scorpio perspective let's talk about
from the Sony E3 perspective what what
do you got to say on this look no I'm
running
Sony what you do to compat combat all
this Scorpio chest out people running
around with the m symbol in the Emoji
what you do shut that on top of games on
top of games on top of games like what
games you have we have games oh did you
see our list that we just dropped oh
that's for real see people think this is
a unicorn and that's not for real be
cool if you can some if you could grab a
hold that that list isz we got an
ongoing back cod with that for the
people who don't know a hard time
finding that list like wait keep talking
why yeah what it is is um there's a leak
that's going out as far as the E3 2017
Sony's press conference and what you
know I think it's been confirmed fake
now though yeah by by by Microsoft heads
because I out fake too
bogus
that alone is
is
indictment it's an indictment against
Microsoft it's an indictment against
their power so if that actually comes
out and if it actually comes to fruition
which I honestly believe it does it
shifts the perspective how do do you
stop a juggernaut with speed and
movement agility the games give them
versatility and Agility the game gives
them different angles that they can hit
you from we got RPGs we got Sports we
got this we have first person shooters
we have this and we have exclusive
content that Microsoft doesn't have yes
I will do they have do they have release
dates is the question no no that's
that's a sorry I'm not gonna sit there
and try to back that
they not g to tell you oh this is coming
out this year no no we have this
development this is coming okay we have
200 games we're
making so you hear that number 200 games
God all right it's it's up it's up on
the screen there we go cool there we go
yeah so uh yeah that
list uh [__] yeah that list I know L sov
I wish you was here right there RO with
K we got uh death
stranding is possible uh we got project
Oscar sounds very suspect what could be
anything could be anything okay God of
War very possible they showed God of War
at the um you know the the little
trailer the teaser trailer oh actually
no it was gameplay it was sh gameplay it
was gameplay in there then we had days
gone which we have seen which we could
see more of that's
possible dreams VR have to defer the
Lord King I don't know anything about
the VR that's a VR game they need a VR
game okay okay Uncharted Lost Legacy now
that's real right isn't real that's real
okay so we're getting almost one4 of the
list and everything seems somewhat true
destiny 2 yes we've just seen it we know
that's going to be on their stage they
have the exclusives um Marvel versus
Capcom infinite do we have any
information that's real they show that
that's real okay crash bandic C and
theme I don't know did we hear crash
team racing Trilogy
that's King just likes that's real
phrase that he keeps saying racing we
heard let's stop Crash Bandicoot real
quick you're gonna tell me that Crash
Bandicoot same Trilogy is not
real do we do we know yeah that's all
three games that's the all three games
in trility that's a remake okay but they
they have announced a crash game right
that's official but is it that a Trilogy
that's the game that's the trilogy I
thought that game already out exactly
I don't know don't know about that this
this this crash team racing is where I'm
like this is vake that's where they lost
me so okay time
out you mean to tell me death stranding
project Oscar is a sucker punch game
that that's they already said they they
was making a game uh God we already know
that days are gone we already know that
dreams VR they need a VR project Oscar I
got a question mark with you though I'm
not there I'm not there yeah but that's
just a trailer okay okay
okay so Uncharted we already know that's
real Destiny 2 we know that's real Mar
versus Capcom we know that's real crash
band that's a Trilogy that they've been
showing gameplay that you can pull up
right now on internet crash team racing
we have no idea if it's real or it's
fake all right now we got Call of Duty
chemical warfare we know the name is
wrong because it look like it's um
they're going I mean we don't
necessarily mean that it's wrong but
it's they we know there's a Call of Duty
coming they going back to what is it War
whatever you know they're doing the
battlefield basically they're basically
mimicking the battlefield formula going
back to the World War II or whatever it
is it may be so okay possibility but
just a technicality with the name right
Kingdom Hearts
three I don't
know Final Fantasy remake no Kingdom
Hearts 3 is already that's already
that's official yeah that's official all
right and then we got Battlefront 2 see
they lost me with that because doesn't
Microsoft have the marketing with that
one well Battlefront
too yeah or does um I'm not sure that I
got to find out is um Battlefront who
has the marketing for Battlefront you
know that adct Lord adct if it's um uh I
think it's Sony yeah I'm not sure so I
just okay so maybe okay well okay so we
about 80% looks like so far as is
leading Lord King's Lord sovereign's way
um Assassin's Creed Empire do we feel a
new Assassin's Creed game will be sh
yes okay Spider-Man they showed a
when you know when's the movie when's
the movie coming what the Spider-Man
movie home de s this year is it July
yeah it's in July but we already saw
that that game is made by Sun punch we
already know that's official game no no
that that that is correct and it it
would make sense from the standpoint the
movies very close would be the month
after E3 and they could it's a Poss is
confirmed
stuff I don't know I don't existence
people have an issue with two games on
this list two four crash team racing and
project Oscar no okay project Oscar is
not the name of the game I know it's
just some random right so project Oscar
can be some indie crap that they
developing in the corner we don't know
then we got resistance 4 right I believe
so and I believe that's a franchise that
they was working on I love this that
franchise then we got uh Gran tesmo
Sport we know that any information on gr
thmo sport yeah they actually have a
beta up running now okay okay bloodborne
too I I don't know I think that maybe
probably be some um DLC uh yeah DLC like
years after the game came out they
talking part two a sequel blood song two
sequel well it could be in the vein of
um look it says clearly says bore uh
blood boore to you DLC say one more D
well you know what let's say they give
you an announcement and there a trailer
and it's going to be like the destiny
reveal trailer that you got Mr
CGI oh did you see game no you did you
saw CGI trailer right they whipped that
together and they threw that up son
gonna whip whole list together and throw
that
up and then what y'all gonna say like
listen for real I we we we we have
already promised the Lords will be doing
a live stream during the Sun
we will be refer will be referring to
this list in the
notes I want y'all to tune in to see
Lord King do the
Shoney when his list is right y'all
don't understand s
coming and the final word is Red Dead
Redemption too which we we know that got
to be true so what are this is 90%
confirmed 70%
I just think it's a reach for all of
that at One E3 yeah I mean to L King's
Point if it is true they would have to
do something to offset Lord Cog
narrative Lord Cognito talk to me care
let me ask you a question how long is
people Sizzle
reals maybe one to three minutes they're
not they're not long yeah they're not
long at all right and in Sizzle res how
many games do they show
um it depends I've seen formats where
they can pack in a bunch you know or
they can just go back you ever seen in
the you estimate damn I'm trying to
remember what didn't they do at Sizzle
reel last time when Scorpio got
announced and that was supposed to be
the PS4 pro segment and they kind of
remixed yeah sizel at the end let's
check this out let's not even do son
let's do a marof Sizzle real remember
the the summer of Sizzle remember that
yeah with all the indie game and they
show Triple A I've never seen
AZ okay let's let's just go with this
let's go with cuphead let's
go if Microsoft put out a list and
cuphead was on that
list y gota it's not confirmed like no
it's confirmed see what people is having
a problem with is time duration
think people leak this list never
putner they have just released the list
with the name and let people debate that
right there because it give Credence to
allow people to say they're not GNA take
time three minutes on this and they not
gonna take four minutes on this and if
they took five minutes on this the show
would be 20 hours long okay let's cut
the whole time off let's throw a Sizzle
reel together of these games announcing
the names and stuff like
that and in that time frame that they
released that Sizzle Reel with all those
games because they don't have a cart
racing game so crash team cart racing
yeah because switch just put out um what
is that card at the end of theth exactly
so why wouldn't you have a cart racing
game whip that up please it sounds
nice I don't know if it's real it sound
nice though first person game this year
from their own sound ER in theory kind
of a situation yeah oh but you know what
they don't have up there they don't have
that Mark Cy crappy game Knack 2 up
there and that's
official let's see they got more games
they got more games than that list even
indicates ABS part no absolutely they
definitely they definitely can do I mean
one thing we have to admit is that you
know Sony is very good as far as their
E3 press conference with with
presentation and trailers and getting
the hype level going even if there is
not necessarily an immediate release
date for this year shout out to Lord
dizy because he just made a point right
now in the chat and he's saying for so
for Scorpio he said do you think that
that Microsoft can show anything at E3
that we can expect to be released in 27
and he said and if not 2017 they say if
not how much bowing ping power would
Scorpio have when the console releases
with nothing so so to speak new than
just
multia well we we know that um two games
are of Microsoft
exclusives um the the forza 7 and
Crackdown and St fig those three
Crackdown is a question mark but we
figured at least four I think CRA is
coming with it oh yeah C th th state of
the G to me personally me L talk about
I'm kind of hyped for State of Decay to
on the low I thought State of Decay was
a sleeper and now that it's conf firm
Scorpio 4K power and they talking about
like a Cooperative Walking Dead Style
game I think that's a sleep on that's
just me personally I think a lot of
people are kind of brushing off State of
Decay too as if okay kind of been there
done that but I love that game if they
really just up like and do everything
that you that you wanted yeah it's me
and you on some Walking Dead and the
resources and we building out poos and
it could be lit to me but anyway
continue continue look yes um I honestly
uh
believe that they're GNA have four
titles and usually a system you know has
no more than four exclusive titles
during their release
period uh you can say you can look over
at the switch that recently have just
done that with a triple trip tripa a
title in Zelda so um and Microsoft's
triaa title which will be the fors of
which actually they launch for if they
sell and they notice that that has been
successful for them also in displaying
the power the system a driving game can
really display your power up front
immediately the
masses completely built for that yep and
that's to get the UK
contention to back it uh because you
know they they're heavy into driving so
I honestly believe that is like it's
geared towards them to get them in and
then you know crack down for us
Americans
Lords yeah want to jump real quick um
what what did you feel about you know
Lord diy's uh question in reference to
um do they do they how much buying power
you think Scorpio will have if it's not
a lot of exclusives in 2017 like let's
say they even announced stuff that's
exclusive but let's say it comes out
2018 or you know to be announced you
know um what do you think about that L
to be honest I kind of feel like they
could really do anything they want
because people going to be so hyped for
the actual console itself like you know
this is only appealing to hardcore fans
and only fans of Xbox and Fanboys are
gonna be picking this up on day one I
don't see no casuals a whole lot of
casuals picking them this this up this
year so
like obviously any Fanboy they don't
care that they'll damage control their
way out of a paper bag when it comes to
this thing so you know that's whatever
and when it comes to you know just fans
like you know
us I would want more but I think it's I
think it's foolish to get your
expectation so high when you know that
the biggest part thing that's coming out
this year is the Scorpio like I do think
they're gonna have something at E3
that's gonna you know really push it but
I don't think it's going to be a whole
lot of games for say Okay okay so you
you think more so they're going to stick
with the strategy of the multiplats
being you know the the Scorpio version
being a superior version graphically I
think that's exactly what they're going
to do I think they're going to be
pushing I do think they're going to
bundle the Scorpio around holiday I do
think they are and I think they're going
to go on that that real slide marketing
that they've done in the past where it's
like we might not have the marketing
deal for Call of Duty for Red Dead
Redemption but we're going to throw the
Scorpio out there pick any of your own
game and pretty much make an
incognito uh bundle with these games
when it's not really a bundle it's like
you pick your own game but we're gonna
ironically drop this bundle out on the
same day Call of Duty comes out go you I
he now what back to original the
original topic with which was L King's
topic with Sony E3 son E3 strategy Lord
adct what do you feel Sony needs to do I
know how we feel about how you feel
about list but what do you feel about
what do they need to do for them to
counter Microsoft and the Scorpio I
don't even think it really matters I
mean even if Sony like just straight up
balls this year like I don't see
Microsoft coming to the to the table
with any extremely significant to take
the Shine off of off of PlayStation
because we know they're gonna come out
there with something I mean PlayStation
ain't Sony ain't gonna come out there
and not announce anything they're gonna
show iconic franchises like God of War
and it's going to take the Shine off of
Scorpio I do think that's one of the
reasons that they jump their their time
ahead of day is because I mean let's be
real here they they're the market share
they have the most fans that's right now
so you know it it take something big
real big to take the Shine off of my off
of Sony but got Point good looking I
just want to say I just
wanna I I'm tired of the rhetoric of
them being the mark Sher leaders right
because are King this is true this is
true this is true
million this is true but I think it it
comes from I need uh a
system to run my movies and play my
games I think they sell to that person
right and that person doesn't buy games
probably buy one or two games a year
that's why their games aren't selling in
the same fashion as uh a dedicated
system as far as like switch let use a
switch um that doesn't have any multi
media functions to it at all nothing
it's just you know kind of make the
argument that Xbox is the multimedia
platform and Sony actually kind of lags
behind because a lot of Sony guys are
like we get our selfish one player
experiences you know you know most of
the most of the exclusives lately have
tend to be not multipl multiplayer games
like muler games what what I mean by
saying this right let's say you take the
PlayStation fan base right and you say
you have that slice it in half and those
are the hardcore guys
right the other guys were the the
um the Whatchamacallit how can you say
the Casual cers those guys pick up one
or two games oh what what game is that H
put it in the Box I'll take it got
Madden okay
cool that c guys the D Bros right so
then you got the other guys that
actually go out six or seven games uh in
two months you know those guys is hard I
gotta finish this this I gota got my
clan I got this I got that I'm on this
you got those guys Microsoft has the
same amount of guys like that but let's
just say uh I think Microsoft casual
user base is lower and we're not selling
to the Casual F we're selling to the
hardcore you know addicts uh the people
that want to play video games and then
we're starting to sell to the techies
that want that 4K to go with he did Phil
Spencer you're right Phil Spencer did
say he's catering this is for the elite
or you know hardcore gamer who a premium
experience kind of you're Aly yeah he's
talking to
me
um so Sony like when Lord addict just
said you know they're gonna put their
games out and and that God of War that's
a game that's game that's game of the
year right there that's that's that's
that game right there that's Flagship
and that's goingon to sell some systems
because you got people that's still out
there just waiting for the new God of
War
um do it does it take the luster off of
a new system I don't think
so that's the question that's a good
point I don't think I don't think God of
War even if it came out date to dat to a
system it won't take the luster off the
system because whatever the allotment
for the Scorpios I believe that they're
going to sell through for the year here
here's the Counterpoint though that I do
see with Lord adak is saying is that oh
I forgot which E3 was it was it wasn't
wasn't last year's what was the E3 which
was like um from Sony priz conference
which was like
shenmu you know Final Fantasy you
whatever and people were like
crying right
so I remember specifically and people
were like so like Microsoft had games
that came out all that year they had
like a great show it was pretty solid
lot of gameplay stuff that was really
being released that year Sony had that
press conference which were like amazing
games that they announced right that
people were very hyped about and I
remember you know people saying clearly
like Sony dominated the press conference
and then I remember taking a screenshot
at the end of the Sony press conference
and you looked at the list of the games
they actually showed and none of them a
maybe 90% 90 I say 80% did not release
were not where had a 2B announced
release date where you didn't even know
when it was coming out or it would be
like the following year or two years
from down and around but the Mind share
was that Sony won the show Even though
games were not
releasing that year so I'm curious to
see is if they if let's say your list is
true L yep and they they knock it out
the PO with all these bombastic
announcements
right the narrative could go again and
say people could say well look look at
all that son's killing it you know and
even though Microsoft has a system
that's out now you know with power with
games that people could be I don't want
say bad
Boozled but people could be overwhelmed
with emotion they could they could be
you know creatures of the
moment and and just listen to it so what
what do you feel about that okay this
this lens to my list being
real remember
told you if the list would would have
dropped that year ahead of time you have
saw Shu on that list you said shut your
mouth de line you would have said
that what is more
farfetched crash team
racing or shenmo or shenmo no you're
right I can't King you got me you got me
I put my hands up yeah you got me I
cannot dispute if you would have gave me
that list that they announced yes that
year with shenmu the Final Fantasy
remake I believe was that this is really
were in their fields like it was a very
emotional e these were beloved games you
know and you're you're right if if that
list is true they will steal the Mind
share once
again Rel even if we have another
Kickstarter
Shen they showed you video of old shenmu
said yeah baby
yeah and people started crying and then
at the end to turn the knife in and to
flick it they said yeah we're starting
to Kickstarter so get your money
together if you want
this they gonna do it they gonna do
hurtful things to you and you're gonna
take
it K I'm not GNA say I'm always seeing
the light of Lord King but I got my
third eye open on you right now you try
to open my third eye list listen that
list is so
real here's the thing though I wanted to
bring to the point for last Sony far as
the E3 conference strategy is that this
is what I think could really be
detrimental and I think me and Lord adct
have also talked about I hav't a chance
to talk to you l king about is that what
I feel which would really put the in to
Microsoft not only if they do this
bombastic list right get everybody in
their fields to me if they say and oh by
the way the PlayStation Pro is now
$300 or 3 they G drop the price if they
drop the price right in conj because at
that point they'll know when Scorpio's
release date is what the price is and
they'll know what the price is so you
know they are the king we got to give
Sony this because they always go second
they're going to drop they're going to
drop the price a week before the Scorpio
comes out exact they can be foul and be
like whatever your day is you're
dropping we're dropping our price now
what the consumer gonna do you see what
I'm saying and that's actually my
biggest fear for Scorpio because people
can like well like well our stuff looks
just as good you know we got the
checkboard we got you know 4K as well
you know not everybody knows the
specifics you know as the hardcore guys
like the hdrs and running 4K you know
what I'm saying like people like oh we
do it too
and that is what I'm that to me is the
biggest hurdle I think Microsoft has to
go through because if if if Scorpio is
as powerful as philis saying it is and
let's just say for all in temps of
purpose my dream of a $400 machine looks
like it's out of it you know right so
let's say it's more likely five right
five to the six
ring9 right so if that's the case if
it's truly this 4K Beast now you got the
I don't want to call it the semi 4K or
the pseudo 4K with the pro but you got a
4K capable machine you got a Pudo 4K
like you okay I'll go with L I have it
so I'm GNA sit here and I'm G I'm gonna
vouch for they 4K nness right and let's
just say there's another rumor going out
you know that there's a possible PS4 Pro
slim I don't know how true this rumor is
again this is all speculation this all
rumor to drop right so if they put that
new at a new price it's kind of enticing
man okay Lord you want jump in on this
because I I got a
tangent no comment okay thank you allow
me to reintroduce
myself yes K now let me explain how uh
we already know son's gonna drop the
price we already know Microsoft is going
to put their price at probably $500
$4.99 whatever um it's higher than
whatever the pro is we know uh Sony is
going to drop the price on they Pro that
what position does that put PlayStation
5 okay um good question good question I
think that
um right now because Sony my answer to
it is that right now because Sony is
such the market leader that it would be
full hearty for them to initiate like
they're in no position to start a new
generation yet because they're so
successful right now to me that would
completely I mean the pro got a little
backlash remember when it got announced
people were like oh I don't really need
this you know what I'm saying I don't
have 4K y y y it was a mixed review when
the pro got revealed so a lot is now
riding on the success of PlayStation
right now there's no need for them to do
the jump they can ride this wave out
they're the market leader you know the
hardware install basee you know there's
no need for the jump so in reference to
five I still think we're ways away I
mean at earliest my guess would be 20
2019 okay I can't see them I think they
they got another two years going right
now of a good run at Lord add what do
you think uh the Scorpio does to the
positioning of the PlayStation 5 and the
of the Pro price that if Scorpio if they
do come out and say that Scorpio is next
Generation I think that Sony about to up
up their PlayStation five plans
drastically because you can't let the
competition have next the next gen
console out for like two years before
right yours drops but it's like I said I
don't think it's a Next Generation if it
is like it's like it's like Lord King
said like Sony will respond with the PS5
in the next year to two mad fast like I
mean they would have to stop the
momentum the only console that I saw
that was prepared to come out at launch
for with this gen was the PS4 like the
Xbox one was clearly not ready you know
when it first launched they pushed it up
to compete with the
PS4 so obviously honestly not ready but
PS4 wasn't ready but PS4 was more ready
than Xbox one was you
not even the ex not even your friends
the notification popup [__] was was was
fun from standpoint it was it was it was
it was completely it was completely a
disaster so you
know there's going to be a cause and
effect if they announce that Scorpio is
their next gen console there will be
some kind of and you know people that
say PlayStation is is you know top
dog if there is just just
a PlayStation's not going to let someone
be out for two years with the nextg
console you know obviously in two years
PlayStation can drop something just as
strong but by then it's the same thing
that was going to happen you know
they're go for two years they're going
to plead they're the they're the
strongest they're you know they're the
most capable they have the better
platform they're not going to let that
happen but here I I hear what you're
saying but you're right I mean I I I can
see my son saying you know what we can't
allow them that's you know two years is
too long but then again I mean we just
when was PS4 Pro announced just last
year right so let's just say in theory
let's just I mean I'm with you 2020 2019
but I don't see the Scorpio being the
next gen I just
don't I mean we'll see we'll see I mean
it's either this a new adapt adaptation
of midc console
refresh or is it we're going you know
you know kind of thing it's going to be
interesting to see that strategy I just
I guess my opinion is just from the
standpoint of you know Sony's just so
successful right now so why would you
upset your base by making the new system
so fast that's just me but well I don't
think they can I think that puts them in
a bad position just like you said Lord I
believe it puts him in a terrible
position in a standpoint as we're so
successful I think that success ises
Hill where whereas Microsoft is kind of
the opposite it's like okay we are
losing we are not going to catch up to
Sony the lead is to we're not that
successful right good point they're
successful from outpacing the you are
correct L they're outpacing at 360 by
far but from a with the competition is
looking towards beating Sony from where
they at from it's impossible and they
don't have yeah Microsoft will never sit
there and play the long con you know a
PlayStation a hardware um company will
play the long con because they know the
averages will average out like the
PlayStation three finally caught up to
the
360 at the end of the life cycle
Microsoft doesn't uh play that because
they're are software company so software
companies has a different mindset that
mindset is more of update refresh get
out the door type of thing and I see
that happening with Scorpio and I um
kind of refute
what Lord addi says when he says that he
doesn't believe Scorpios to be the next
actually I believe the Scorpio to be
more capable of the Next Generation I
thought this generation was more um Half
Baked so I believe that that Scorpio is
a more thought out uh approach to the
generational Gap and what Microsoft has
adopted is we we're going to take our
software being that we're soft company
and we're going to make it playable
along our long line of products the vi
the vi I agree with you King I think the
vibe I'm getting from Microsoft is
you're almost taking like a a phone
approach you know like you know like
iPhone which is like you know we're GNA
we're not leaving you old guys behind
right now so but you know if on the
newer phone you know everything's G to
look better everything's going to be
more powerful you know you're going to
be able to do a little bit more and for
the guys who are not ready you know you
still can play you know these existing
games kind of thing so I think that may
be just something that we're not used to
from a console perspective yes but um
conso yes this is good stuff it's going
to be interesting we got E3 we got
Scorpio reveals we got Sony strategy
countering it's going to be really
really fun so I wanted to move on if
everyone if the Lord's got everything
off on that and um talk about our next
topic which would
be maybe rest in peace GameStop Lord
Lord adct what do you what do you got to
say about this this be this be it for we
could we be over well you know obviously
digital sales Amazon all this they
they've really
impacted you know GameStop game pass as
well but that's not out so I don't think
that I think Game Pass itself being
announced destroyed the shares but the
right even without game pass it might
have took longer but the writing's been
on the raw even GameStop you know higher
up manag has realized this that's why
they've went down to selling phones you
know they've partnered up with companies
like Cricket so I could see this
completely happening you know a lot of
people want to you know they want to say
that it's been more on Amazon I do think
Amazon's hurt GameStop a lot Amazon done
a lot but the thing is is Amazon is
still selling physical media and I think
at the end of the day that physical
media ends up right back at GameStop so
I don't think it's M on game uh Amazon
that's hurting GameStop CU game they
don't get a whole lot of money from
selling new games it's like right it's
like 10 five or 10 percent you know
they're pretty much just like taking a
little bit of the
cut if you buy stuff from Amazon chances
are you're gonna show right back up to
GameStop because you're not going to
trade it back in to Amazon you could buy
stuff Amazon because you get it pretty
much you get it day you get it the day
day one it comes out you know so it
doesn't really affect you but you don't
want to to trade stuff back into Amazon
because you got that in your hand you
want that new game you know done with it
you know Amazon uh does buyb they have
buyback program well they they they buy
it back but a lot of people want it they
they want to trade their stuff in right
then and there and get the new stuff
right then and there so you know I can
give you a different perspective but go
ahead so I think it's Ma I think digital
sales is is hurting GameStop a lot more
now because yes you could see clearly
that you know you go into GameStop the
Shelfs are empty compared to last gen
there's there's half of the games there
you know it used to be you wi in games
stop there's like five or six Call of
Duties now it's like one or two you know
they they've had to redisplay how they
display games they used to have it uh
you know facing sideways so they can fit
more games now they're facing it
frontwards where you could see the the
front of the case because there's not as
many games to show and I've I've worked
in retail it's all about how you display
your product so they have to make it
look better so you know they said
they're closing 240 GameStop's closing
down I think they have like 7,000 or
8,000 and all so it's a small percentage
I think they said it's like six% or four
or five percent so it's not the end of
the world
now but I think games I think right now
Game Pass is
just to to this to the to this this
subscription thing think Ubisoft
Activision all of them are going to jump
on this eventually and when we see more
of these Services pop up I think every
time one of these subscriptions pop up
it cuts GameStop's lifespan in
half oh
yeahp yeah I'm gonna give you where the
Genesis of this whole thing started from
the Genesis and the demise of GameStop
started way before all of that started
with
GameFly once GameFly was introduced it
gave you a cheap alternative to playing
the games that you
wanted at a discount price you got to
test it and um a lot of people were
going inside uh GameStop and purchasing
games and weren't happy with it and then
the resale value of said game that you
purchased five minutes ago was
drastically reduced to Pebbles you
brought a bow there and you walked out
to the parking lot and you put it inside
and you played it you ah sucks you came
right back in was like um no I'll take
the the Call of Duty instead sir okay
we're GNA give you $10 credit for this
excuse me I just gave you
5950 oh no no yeah so that would with
fun fact I remember when Resident Evil 5
came out I had to just shits and giggles
like I was like yeah I want to trade
this in literally day one purchase and
the dude was like what excuse me and I
was like I just want to trade it in and
he's like I first off I can't take it
because it's in the case uh if if the
Plastics on that they they won't take a
game back so uh I was like okay I was
like theoretically if I want to trade
this I'm just curious they were offering
me like $24 and it just came out king is
not and then they're just gonna turn
that around put a $55 price tag on put
it up on the ship yes oh okay so that
turn that started the
jadedness uh and with them you know you
started getting the ey of the public and
then it started with
streaming uh companies to stream games
and you know we had a couple We we
played them and we like oh that's nice
you get a bunch of games for a different
price and little by little the stock uh
started
dropping with uh GameStop then Amazon
started saying hey you can get the
systems day and date of release yep
why do I need to go stand on the
line you know and be self-promotion for
GameStop because you know GameStop takes
pictures of all of us standing outside
to build up the height and make you feel
a part of a group hey I want to be part
of that late night out there with the
people mixing it
up no I want to be part of the people
sleeping in my bed and my system comes
at the door and I pick it up and I put
inside the house and I go about my
business and I have to worry about being
robbed the murder you know you want the
JS you want the no
heyo you know what happened that day
with the PlayStation 2 you know you me
and you we were in the street it was bad
in them streets it was really bad you
know and I I you nailed it with the
midnight launch I mean I know that's
what kind of all that stuff you know got
me away from that and you got sites like
Amazon and I mean shout out to even BB
too I think um got to switch
yeah straight delivered to the house or
you can have it where it's delivered to
the store if you don't you know you
don't want it mail to you got you could
do so many options but continue look I
didn't want to cut you right so the
downward spiral started from there
screwing over the public I thought the
the the real nail in the coffin and I
know Lord addict said you know they they
announced the game pass I thought the
real nail in the coffin was the expose
that was put out on them with that
Circle of Life craft yo it's funny you
said that cuz shout out to Lord DIY he I
was literally going to comment he just
put that in the chat in the live chat
and he saying he just then he said he
said how much did that hurt them he said
shares were going down and now people
seeing those dirty tactics and them
trying to force use copies and stuff
like that that's a huge one there it
took away the let's let's say if it's
pros and cons and you have people
standing on the the pros of it it took
away their argument whatever argument oh
they're not into dirty tactics no way
they upstair what the video's out yes
the video's out we got
them they're lying so now you sit there
you say well do I do I stick with them
no you don't stick with them you let
them burn
like let that dumpster fire burn out and
let's move on let's move into the Next
Generation where everything is digitally
downloaded you can play it anywhere the
same place Microsoft has been pushed us
and we've been screaming kicking and
yelling trying not to go in this
Direction that's a good point that's a
good point iron of it is kind of
funny it's
ironic yeah I mean I want to jump in on
this too it's just like it's just a
perfect storm I mean it's one of those
things where you know outside of you got
circle of life you know that expose that
definitely hurt them negatively from a
public standpoint I believe CEO one of
those guys had to make a public
statement reference to it that's never
good you know I got inside information
on them I have people who actually um
were interested in some colleagues of
mine to work you know for GameStop from
a buying standpoint and you know they
they're doing a whole marketing shift
their whole thing is now is you know if
you look um Lord King you know you mean
you from New York area you know if you
remember the big GameStop 34th Street
remember that was like one of the big
Flag Street not remember across from the
Macy's over that one remember the big
one okay now if you look go to the
stores you'll see it's GameStop
ThinkGeek yep and Think Geek is this new
thing they're trying to force in where
it's like you know geek clothing video
game wear like all you know toys so it's
like their closing stores that's not
profitable and in conjunction trying to
move this new Direction with gear and
stuff so to me the riding was on the
wall because one of my boys like I said
I got an inside source was you know
applying for them for a big- time job
with them and he was telling me he was
like oh no they're going Think Geek like
they are they're going to open up all
these Think Geek stores and you know
this is the new wave crate right because
they know the used industry Market it
it's bleeding them right now and with
digital going into self-publishing too
yes yeah saying with digital being so
prominent I mean think about the last
two years I I like I've now mentally
gotten to the point where it's like say
if there's a game I'm on the fence with
I'm like I know you know Xbox or you
know Sony's going to do that you know
fall sale right gonna be like 30 50% off
then you got you know these games with
gold discounts PS4 discount PS you know
PS4 now PlayStation Now discounts it's
so many discounts and you're doing it
from the convenience in your house so
then I said to myself okay so all right
I'll just go to GameStop for accessories
and systems but you kind of don't need
to do that either like you kind of just
Amazon it to your house Best Buy it to
your house so they really I think it's
just the perfect storm of all these
things happening to them and you know
obviously Game Pass didn't help they
they tried to announce some similar um
program GameStop they were offering with
used games I thought was kind of funny
the day like after the week games Game
Pass was announced they're in trouble
they're in trouble and I think right now
it could be one of those things you know
Lord adct where l king is just
that it could be you know five years
from now I think I was having this
conversation with L Sinister and you in
the chat and we were like it could be
one of them things you're telling your
kid like yeah we used to do this thing
called
gam and we used to stand out online and
you know what I'm saying and I don't
know you know I don't know shout out to
Lord Disney say GameStop could win us
back offer digital codes to games inside
of the collector edition offering
exclusive goodies for
them I don't
know you're
disillusion over it it just seems it
feels it for the first time and I know
what people saying for a long time you
want to jump in no that
was I'm going to GameStop right
now literally my son and I are going to
jump in the car after the podcast and
I'm going to go buy a doctor strange
statue I'm not buying a game yeah that's
part that's part of the thing I mean
honestly I went the GameStop the last
time I went was either to reserve some
ridiculous collector edition that goes
out fast online right or the last
purchase I went was the breath of the
wild
amiibo amiibo yeah those amiibos are
nice yeah you know we did the to on
Theos a couple little podcast ago we
know the power of those with Zelda
but but yeah I mean it it's it's not
looking good man you going there for
things other than games yeah yeah
man you agree you thinking you thinking
it might be how how much longer you giv
it I think five to seven years two years
oh you you think oh wow you still think
you got them holding they got enough
money to hold off two
years look K like two years two years
the physical media is still very
dominant they'll be while they'll be
around for a while now are they are they
willing to just call it quits and not
put money into a dying brand is the
better
question think they become
kios got red boxes I think they become
kios where you go because they have kios
set up now where you can sell your cell
phones right and I was looking at it the
other day and I said okay this is where
they can save money on uh because a lot
of time you spend money on physical
locations and you spend money on
employees uh you can save all that money
in maintenance and Servicing right
you're actually right you're right
because my boy's a buyer and he's
telling me like in retail the days of
these big storefronts is over it's over
like yeah it's a waste of money it's not
financially you know viable it's not
really smart for for a company to do it
these
days
so what happens now is they put up these
kiosks where they have new games you
could purchase new games or you can
purchase used games and you can trade in
your used game the kios will take the
game read the game see that the game
doesn't have any scratches uh whatever
and give you trade credit towards
whatever game that you want to purchase
that's inside of the
kiosk that's the only way gam stop Will
Survive we gota see we gotta see if they
hold on maybe think ke saves them who
knows two years he said two we gota we
go to we got to record this one and come
back play the tape see what happens with
that's right we're in 2017 right 2019
they closed more than 50% of their
stores they're moving in a different
direction well it might be already
happening like I said I mean that's what
it that's what it seems like they're
doing now they they're already going to
look at one stores that are not
profitable yeah and they're going to
close those stores that's a fact they've
already kind of come out and said that
stocks and then we do know Think Geek is
the direction that is definitely I've
got you know a fact from an inside
store I can give you a highest
what you think remember when every
GameStop on system launch was open for
midnight launch yes they're not doing
that anymore they're not doing that
anymore yeah I noticed that I'm noticing
now certain Gamestops are saying hey
yeah we're not doing a launch I'm like
wow that would never happen like
especially with a big release and I
found out why talk to me they do not
want to pay the
overtime that it would take for them to
keep the store open pass working hours
uh another six to seven hours and pay
the employees and the
security for that they said no they can
pick the system up in the
morning that's when Amazon comes in and
Amazon wins because Amazon say hey we do
the same exact thing and you can stay in
the comfort of your home valid point
valid point as long as same thing with
digital sales too I mean download you
don't have to be online midnight
Midnight it goes live on the digital
server and people are download playing
house so yeah yeah I was pissed off when
I had away from my physical copy uh from
Gamestop it was one year and I saw you
live playing the game at night I was in
my house on
fire I turn my system off and I went to
bed because I had no other choice but to
go to sleep and
that you were having so much fun and you
was so far ahead of me by the time I got
my physical copy the next day
from you're right I mean I see it you
know I see it firsthand when people are
just like hey we gonna download that
digital then then we we been getting one
of the biggest d game sharing yeah like
game sharing is huge that Microsoft is
admitting I mean not admitting it but
actually officially announcing it as
part of a feature you know they actually
getting behind it again it's like you
know what the other incentive like you
and your your man could could got you
know can purchase a game share Library
you know that's huge yep that's huge cut
down on other purchas two purchases cut
down on two purchases yeah so but on
that note that's what we got on GameStop
and uh good show good show it's good to
be back in the mix so uh Lord King where
can the people find you uh you can find
me on Instagram at the real King David
OTW you can find me on Twitter on King
David OTW you can find me on Xbox Live
King David OTW and you can find me on
PlayStation Network on Xbox 360
lover Savage that is so Sav soon the
bearded Brothers podcast yes
near you up and of course I'm R from
another mother Lord addict what's going
on with you where can the people find
you what else is going on with you you
can find me um on YouTube gaming addict
uh I have a find me on Twitter um I
think it's Lord addict IOP I don't know
it might be gaming addict IOP you can
find me on Xbox Live uh Playstation and
and um at room to kill that's my
gamertag and my PSN I ain't on
Playstation a whole lot I I I do have a
Vita but you can um you still got one
yeah you can and uh switch room to kill
switch yeah but I ain't giving you that
social security stuff or and you can
find me on um on Steam at gaming addict
but uh I do appreciate you guys uh
working with us for the past couple
weeks we've had technical issues I did
fix all the hyperlinks in the
description to everyone's correct social
media that's what I've been doing I know
I've been kind of quiet I'm kind of
tired too but uh definitely catch catch
me on my YouTube channel I I post pretty
de uh pretty regular content on there
you know yeah man uh Lord Cognito and
both uh Lord uh Kings both bit on my
addict shows but uh thanks for watching
shout out Reno right now he said uh Lord
is in the building ah my man s is in the
building before we close I just want to
give a shout out to it real quick um
yeah definitely not to cut you L that
appreciate all you guys sticking with us
we we had to you know rest in peace you
know we give our condolences to Skype we
no longer dealing with them ever
again for the guys that you know that
stuck with us we really appreciate you
we're hearing better feedback quality
we're not trying to get out of our mom's
basement Lord C said you could catch him
online on the raid we got you Lord s you
know what saying and um yeah this L
Cognito here also catch me on Twitter
you already know L Cognito Xbox is
Cognito and um what you call PSN is cogn
360 switch we're not giving out those
you know sensitive
details too much Nintendo right there
it's too much Lord Disney catch me
outside how about
that I see you love this yo but like I
said appreciate you sticking with us we
got a lot of things cooking now that we
got all this audio garbage behind us we
are going to be hitting you in the head
with a lot of content great guest things
are going to be bubbling and uh it's on
we still the best podcast you never
heard and we got a lot of things going
way till E3 you guys are going to be
surprised we got some things cooking out
there too but I'm give it back to you
Lord addict and you're going to say you
closing things out pieace us out of
here like I said thank you guys for uh
staying with us we'll definitely be on
here now since we got the audio issues
I'm looking into more guests you know to
to get more of a variety of guests on
here uh I have been looking at the the
retention rate we have I appreciate you
guys you guys has been watching a pretty
decent amount of the the
podcast this uh this podcast but it's
like I said we'll see you we'll see you
next week we're going to try to come up
with a a time to be consistent every
week instead of being like 1 to 11 to
one we're gonna try to everyone come
together and have one specific time
every week uh sorry that you guys missed
Lord Sovereign he he had some personal
issues he had to deal with he'll be back
next week yeah Lord Lord SWAT they'll be
back whenever they get
back back like I said there always round
T seat for those so uh thank you guys
for watching we're definitely we're out
of here
peace